all right welcome everyone to my lecture
on pawn structures or pawn something
okay we're gonna just talk about pawns
so pawn is an amazing piece right
basically a lot of palm structure
elections have to do with the particular
type of structure whether it's hanging
pawns or isolated pawns a particular
pawn structure like a Carlsbad which
we're actually gonna look at today but I
really those things are fairly typical
and a lot of people do them I've
certainly done them I might do them in
future weeks but what I wanted to do
today was actually focus more on
flexibility with palm structures because
this game I found very interesting this
was played quite recently in the Tata
Steel tournament between Peter Svidler
and - - extremely strong grandmasters
and I found what was interesting about
this game was how many times not just
one pawn structure but how many times
the pawn structure changed and how both
players had to adapt to how the pawn
structure changed so that's kind of what
I wanted to focus on because so many
games you know so many lectures really
people focus on say isolated palm but
how often do you get an isolated pawn
and then you don't have anymore
you push it the Dom structure changes
how do you adapt to when it changes and
that's kind of what I want to focus on
today I'll probably go off the rails as
usual but at least give it a shot so c4
so we get a Queens gambit declined
Bishop before slightly unusual I find
that one of the things I find very
interesting in these super tournaments
is that you know people will actually
play offbeat stuff more often than you'd
think and the reason is just people
study these openings so much they want
to at least get something kind of fresh
and probably boy fun didn't expect this
from Svidler Spitler usually plays like
maybe some c4 Knight f3 or 1.e4 and
probably she's just like you know what I
don't want to deal with whatever you
prepared I'm gonna play
but of course I'm speculating it could
have nothing to do with that
so they actually end up with a with a
fairly mainstream line the Rogozin and
Spitler decides now to surprise he takes
and plays Bishop f4 so the main line
here is the bishop going to g5 and it
gets extremely sharp I don't want to
focus too much in opening but there's
also Queen a4 check lines which are
interesting there are plenty of
opportunities but oke please Bishop for
so you're asking yourself why on earth
would you not pin the knight but this
move has some subtle points there are
times when actually after Bishop g5
black can play h6 g5 on you and kind of
kick your bishop with gain of time 94
also can hit your Bishop with a tempo
here it does not and it's simply
developing the bishop before you do play
e3 so when you think about it logically
it's actually a very normal move and I
believe it's a trend that people are
doing now but I always like to ask
myself when I see a move I don't know
what exactly is up what are they up to
with this move so that's what the deal
with Bishop f4 is black castles and
white plays rook c1 so my first question
to you guys is why wouldn't white play
the more obvious move here to my eyes at
least which is III why would white play
rook c1 first to me that move looks a
little strange but you're absolutely
right I mean there are definitely white
wants to support that night but is there
a particular reason yeah yeah keep in
mind why it's not developed yet so white
just wants to get developed and get
castled and then start playing white
doesn't have any plans of applying to
play C 3 C 4 or anything like that most
likely white just wants to get developed
first if you try to do stuff like that
before you're developed usually very bad
things happen to you I know so that
could be my theory was actually that she
was worried about or sorry he was
worried about c5 and the idea is that
now after takes
there's this move along with whatever
noises are being made and this looked
really annoying to me because the
Knights come in e4 if you play rook see
one you have to contend with Queen takes
a two and not that this is that clear
usually white can sack some pawns and
get castle the nap compensation but
probably he just didn't want to do with
this he wanted the structure to remain a
little bit more so what I'm looking for
a little bit more stable a little bit
more concrete once you play e3 c5 the
pawn structure becomes loose and the
fact that you have a king in the center
can really work against you so he
decided to go with this so now the idea
is if c5 is played now and white takes
Queen a5 doesn't work out so well
because I can simply play a3 so that's
why you know I think rook c1 was played
it seems like a subtle thing but I
always ask myself in the openings like
why are these guys doing this like what
exactly is the point of this before and
I find that you can actually learn a lot
about different openings and different
structures by asking this question so
black decides all right no c5 for me
I'll just play c6 and now the claim that
her claim is that well not your real
quick silly on c1 in Karlsbad structures
the rook often doesn't want to be here
because I mean what's it really doing
this is not an open file really but okay
normal enough III it's actually quite
funny I'd say the bishop on b4 and rook
on c1 are both slightly wrong now so she
plays Bishop d6 which is a fairly normal
move trading these bishops it looks a
little strange to trade the bishop
that's not on the opposite side it color
of your pawn chain but in Karlsbad I'd
say all bishop trades are quite good for
black because black tends to have a
little less space so the bishop trade
usually will actually help out so you
know but I'd say the trade of light
squared bishop stennes to be more
important and this is kind of what I
mean by pawn structure knowledge like
takes takes first to know exactly what
your goals are when you have this
structure and by the way any bonus
points for knowing which structure this
is
indeed I'm just making sure people
listen that happens but yeah this is a
Carlsbad structure so what do you guys
know about a Carlsbad structure it's
important to kind of get your bearings
to figure out like what do I know about
this structure what happens yeah I mean
it's it's tricky like if you don't know
it's hard to figure it out so you know I
don't expect you guys to guess and stuff
like that but I'd say like one of the
things I would recommend and I can tell
you that almost all GM's I know do this
which is that even if I don't play a
particular structure I'll try to learn
about it like one of the things that
you'll notice is that GM's no matter
what pawn structures on the board will
kind of have an idea now if it's an
opening we play we'll know all the ins
and outs if it's an opening we don't
play we'll be like yeah I'm not exactly
sure but this is kind of where you play
this is kind of what happens this is the
breaks
we won't know all the details but we'll
kind of know how it works and it's
amazing how often this kind of thing
comes in handy to know about different
pawn structures so learning the Carlsbad
is such a classic structure I would say
even if you never play it learning a
little bit about it can be useful so
there's a lot to go into usually there
are multiple plans for white usually
pushing on the Queen sides a plan
trying to create weaknesses black white
can plate 95 and try to put a cement
that night y can try to play f3 for this
is usually in positions within a Tony to
but that can happen so there are
multiple plans and one of the things I
would say that separates people who
plays positions extremely well for white
and people who don't is people who play
them really well are not attached to one
plan they can play on the Queen side
they can play in the center whereas if
you watch a lot of like amateur players
they have one plan and no matter what
you do that's the plan they're going for
and I just think it's a very poor
mentality
it sounds like an obvious thing but I
think we've all been guilty of it at
some point so staying flexible with your
plans is an important thing but to
return to the exact moment here because
you have to play a move one of the most
common themes here is that black wants
to trade the bishops which is something
I told you before so if you black
already traded the dark square Bishop
but I would say the light square bishop
are even more important if black can
trade off the light squared bishop even
for a night it's quite advantageous
because then black has no real bad peace
the Knights come out you put your pieces
and you can usually combat any of whites
plans if you have fewer pieces on the
board whites plans become far less
effective so here's Fiddler in my
opinion played a very clever move and
it's the only move which at least to my
opinion makes blacks life a little
complicated
it's not even objectively that much
stronger than any other move probably
but it's the move the only move I would
not want to face as black so what do you
what are your ideas it's to do with the
bishop on c8 so h3 would be a very
direct move right not directs maybe the
wrong word but it prevents Bishop g4 but
what does it allow there's you have five
correct so many yeah don't don't don't
put your pieces on the edge of the board
without a clear purpose that they don't
like it they'll resent you the rest of
the game it's not something you want
yeah okay so Bishop d3 would be a
normal-looking move however black would
play this now you have the pin nothing
horrible has happened
it's not like Oh Bishop g4 just off for
a draw the game's over but blacks pretty
comfortable now because black plays
ninety seven pieces come out all the
blacks pieces make sense right so his
move strive to disrupt that
95 I'd say it's a little too soon you're
not quite developed enough for 95 you
have to be very careful trying to play
moves like this before your fully
developed I would say queen bee 3 is
actually quite interesting
I don't mind queen bee 3 is just
sometimes the Queen looks funny there
later he I opted for Queen c2 which is a
similar idea so it looks like kind of a
silly move compared to developing a
bishop right but it prevents Bishop f5
just making sure we're on the Payette
same page
and Bishop g4 now runs into which move
95 with temple on the bishop right so
again its moves like this that can make
the subtle difference between ending up
with putting a little pressure on your
opponent or allowing them to get an easy
game and it's moves that sometimes
people fast forward on so I'm not saying
you got to think 10 minutes on Queen c2
but spend a couple minutes figure out
what's going on and maybe you'll find a
move that puts more pressure on black
because you have to admit whether this
moves that much better or not it's more
unpleasant to face because now black has
to make a choice well how exactly do I
develop right so black played rook e8 y
played Bishop d3 97 castles all pretty
logical right Knight f8 so
this was another interesting position I
would say so black simply trying to get
pieces out and trying to get our pieces
forces kind of settled and I don't think
that there are there's only one good way
to play for white and I'm sure there are
plenty of good moves trying to play for
B for for example I think would be quite
reasonable however white decided that
the best move to play for the best plan
to go for was Knight to e5 we talked
about this plan right cementing a knight
on e5 and trying to put upon an f4 right
so the question is what happens if white
plays ninety five immediately yes
ninety six is possible however after I
play f4 I kind of have what I want you
never ever want to take this Knight and
if you play f6 your your knight it's
gonna be very loose right so I think
that this is exactly what Y would be
looking for but adjust your move a
little bit yeah
night 6:57 I can still play f4 that's
the move you want to not allow night 657
might be playable because after have for
I don't know 960 d7 is possible but you
don't you'd rather not have to play up
six I would say yeah yes now have four
is impossible because there's pawn hangs
so black white would have to probably
trade and as we've discussed which side
do trades favor almost always black
there are rare occasions where it's not
true but that kind of train would be
helpful so instead white played here so
again I have a question and I'd like
honest answers usually I don't that's
why I'm specifying how many of you would
have if you were playing over this game
would have saw h3 and be like alright h3
and kept going without pausing you
probably would just play over this right
that's why again I like to pause on
these moves ask yourself why is he
playing h3 why couldn't he just play a
95 immediately and almost always you'll
find an answer but these with these guys
they're so strong that I mean not that
they don't miss things of course they
make mistakes and miss things but
usually almost always there's a very
specific purpose to move orders and why
they're doing what they're doing and one
of the reasons they're slightly better
than weaker grandmasters is that they
get these things right a little bit more
often in any case I'm not saying h3 is
even the best move it's more like if
you're gonna play for a 95 you need to
prepare it so black plays g6 white plays
95 sure enough Knight h5 a little bit of
an unusual move but believe it or not
it's actually not that atypical for
these types of positions what do you
think blacks ideas by the way and again
we're gonna assume she knows what she's
doing
uh yeah that's the idea that if 95 94
you have to trade off the knight which
isn't what you want so that's why white
played h3 yeah
ah we're here you can't be up to realize
this night is not very good here it
prevents 95 temporarily but this night
blocks all your other pieces you can't
develop this fix this Bishop with that
way she tries to do it in the game you
can't really move this night
you're just it does prevent 95 but
you're kind of stuck and being stuck is
usually not a good thing because your
opponent can switch plans on you right
and then you're like wait why is my
knight on g6 not I mean so I'd say in
general in these structures your knight
does not want to be here
it would much rather be elsewhere and
we'll go over where that is later but 9
h5 looks like a funny move so white
plays rook e1 but what exactly is the
purpose of Knight h5 it's quite possible
but I would say that one of the whole
reasons of playing 95 is not just to put
her knight on e5 the 95 doesn't really
do that much right it's just sitting
there but if you provoke f6 Black has a
weakness for ever and I'll again this is
something I think a lot of players don't
appreciate which is that you play more
like f6 you never put it back if white
then opens the center on you starts
complications you're gonna have to deal
with that weak King on g8 you're gonna
have to deal with this this bad pawn
structure so White's hoping not
necessarily that you you know that this
nights gonna be super strong but that
you're gonna get sick of having it there
and force the knight out
yeah floor black I would not recommend
this then this Knight becomes an
absolute monster do not make this knight
become stronger than it already is but
why is but why did why play this it's
actually nothing to do with that pawn at
all
whoa you can but I wouldn't recommend it
just yet I'd say that you're sacking in
exchange for a pawn right would you say
it's a position that's gonna remain
closed a long time I don't think so
I would say that if you sack this
exchange you need something more to work
with white needs a weakness white needs
something bad I like that you're
thinking the exchange that it's a good
thing but you can't do it when it's just
you get a pawn and white has no
weaknesses whatsoever you're not gonna
get enough for your exchange you'd need
something a little bit stronger
indeed so there was there was one subtle
point which is that if white tries to
play a four now sometimes 93 is annoying
which is why white played rookie one but
another point is that often the net will
drop back to g7 and not play Knight f5
but what do you think the idea of nine
g7 would be or what is blacks problem
peace what peace does black want to
trade off
exactly if black can achieve [ __ ] at
night g7 Bishop f5 blacks doing a lot
better because once you trade off that
Bishop your life becomes a whole lot
easier so this is actually a very
typical idea in Karlsbad structures g6
97 notice how unlike positions will say
the knight on g6 not to pick on your
move too much you have mobility there
you have ideas you have things you can
do and you always want to make sure
that's kind of the case so this is a
very typical idea here so white played
sorry it was blacks boom black played
rookie 7 this moves a little mysterious
to me I have to admit I thought she
could just play in a g7 immediately but
it could be she was worried about white
switching plans and as I mentioned
switching plans is an important thing
you have to do right you can't just be
too carried away with your own plan
maybe white could try this by the way
this is a very common thing when your
opponent kind of delays stuff too much
maybe creates weaknesses open the
position so even though efore
technically creates a weakness
look at this initiative you're getting
Knight takes this squares week 9 g5 is
in the air Bishop c4 is in there all of
a sudden it's like whoa where'd this
come from right and the reason it's
possible is because black fiddled around
a little too much so she didn't want to
allow this I still am not crazy about
this rookie 7 move to me it looks a
little slow but here Smither finds a
very very interesting way to deal with
this move Minh he plays a move here
which I actually really like plays this
now you're thinking Queen a4 against
rookie 7 Josh you've been you've been on
something but
he has a really clever idea yeah b4 b5
exactly now you'll see why having the
rook on e7 is particularly good with
this idea in the first place but but
yeah so basically the 95 is done all it
can do right so we discussed this you
can't just have one plan you need to be
flexible so now he's gonna switch to
playing on the Queen side but you'll see
why this is opportune at the moment so
black plays 97 so first of all what do
you do here
that's the natural reaction right the
whole reason you played all your moves
was that you can play off four but I
actually think f4 is a very bad mistake
here black can just do this force you
back Knight g3 and all of a sudden wait
a second what's happened bishop can come
out to have five and I can come to see
for these pawns are actually kind of
weak right how did this happen
and the way isn't it happened is because
the position changed you're no longer
ready to play f4 but that's no problem
what did he play
you got to be careful when you get too
ambitious with your palm bushes it's
very easy keep in mind where are you
playing what side of the board are you
playing on you're playing mostly here
for now if you try to play push all your
pawns your kings gonna end up quite weak
so in general I'd say unless you're
prepared for this if you had all your
pieces concentrated on the Queen side
I'm sorry on the Kings side I'd say you
could try that idea maybe but because
your Queens out on a for your rooks are
over here you're not prepared to play on
the Kings side you applied to play on
the Kings side you're just gonna weaken
your own king he plays a very simple
move and again I think this is a move
that a lot of players who aren't as
experienced are just not gonna look at
well yes but you have an immediate
problem here cuz you don't want to trade
right yeah just go back what's the
problem and again it's like people they
go forward they assume they can't go
back of course you can go back it's a
free country
and the point is that now wait a second
this night just went back here and here
this night now doesn't make sense you
can change your plans
just because you played ninety five
doesn't mean you must play f4 doesn't
mean the police are gonna knock down
your door if you don't sometimes going
backwards is the way to go because now
black is not well equipped to deal with
this b4 idea so I think she should have
tried Knight b6 or something here but
instead she played Knight d f6 which
Tamiya looked a little strange but okay
he plays b4 and this is where what he
did really comes in handy because now if
the rook were back on e8 and black were
able to get this Bishop out black would
be much better equipped to deal with
this b5 push but because the rooks can't
connect how do you stop b5 here that's
what she did and now
whoops and this was his idea because the
rooks are disconnected this is an easy
move to play so it's kind of a cool
little trick so she kind of panicked
here she took and then played here which
I actually think is is quite bad and
this is what I mean by pawn structure
changes so this has happened so there
are tactics here which we'll get to but
forgetting the tactics for just a moment
and usually I'm not gonna say the words
forget the tactics so be thankful what
what has happened to the pawn structure
yeah this pawn is a little lonesome
right I wouldn't call it a weakness just
yet but in the long term having this
pawn could be quite annoying what else
I said to forget check this forget
tactics I'm just talking about pawn
structure mm-hmm yeah so sometimes the
two versus one if the pawns can get far
advanced can be quite dangerous so it's
something white has to worry about in
the future and again I mean it's it's
one of those things I would say that I
just know from experience these pawns
take a long time to get going it's not
easy for these pawns to actually create
something here but at the same time it's
something which in the long term is
something you have to worry about but I
would say that and again I'm really
saying forget tactics for the moment
we'll get to tactics there are plenty of
them we'll get to again I'm really this
this lecture is largely pawn structure
focused but as you keep pointing out and
as your brain keeps screaming at you
which it should you have a tactic here
however what I want to focus on first is
get the positional bases and then look
for your tactics during a game if you
look for tactics first that's cool but
the main thing is I think that people
sometimes forget to keep track of what's
changed when a pawn structure changes
you should be aware of it you should not
be playing the position you were playing
when the pawns before the pawn structure
changed so another thing I would point
out is that white has control over the
main file that's not good for black
right White's pieces are a bit better
this night on h5 I still don't
understand what it's doing now so I
think that that's where the basis for
whites advantage is not so much pawn
structure because again is this a
weakness not really not for the moment
White's main advantage is due to its
superior pieces now that we've moved to
that someone has a tactic I think yes no
and I like that you're this is this is
very a very good thing that you
immediately spot this because this is
you know tactical eye is very important
and believe it or not Svidler missed it
I can't believe I cannot believe it this
is a very strong tactical player he
usually would see this if you wake them
up at 3 a.m.
he's half asleep he would probably spot
this immediately but for some reason
during the game he just lost his mind so
what is the tactic okay so you're
attacking the rook it doesn't really
have a great move because I've looked
back to eight you play Knight b6 right
so the rook has to go to a six and the
rook is officially out of squares if it
goes to c6 what happens if it goes here
yep how could such a strong player miss
something so simple my guess is he just
wasn't on the lookout maybe he was
thinking to positionally he was thinking
about pawn structure he's thinking about
other things but all I know is his move
to me makes no sense
he played this now forget about the
tactic for a minute why on earth would
you give up your file it's all very
strange but we'll ignore it for now he's
a much stronger player than I am I'm
sure he had reasons but he definitely
didn't find the best move in this
instance holy fun doesn't need to be
asked twice she pushes her pawn yeah and
here he actually plays another bad move
so my guess is sometimes when you don't
see the position clearly when you're
missing stuff you're prone not just to
make one bad move you're prone to make
many in a row now he makes two in a row
but I'd say one of the things super gems
tend to be good at is when the position
changes or they miss something they're
good at resetting do you guys know what
I mean by resetting basically you're
like all right I missed something
forget everything I thought I knew about
the position I'm gonna figure everything
out again where do my pieces belong what
are the tactics what's going on
if you don't reset you're gonna keep
missing things until usually you lose so
resetting is a very important thing to
do when you blunder when you miss
something big and I have no doubt that
he knew something was up there's no way
he's played this and was like yeah it's
all fine so going back what should white
play here do you think
hmm that's the move I like put the rook
on the file
I still think White's better here you
still have the file this Bishop it's a
little funny I don't mean haha funny but
doesn't look right to me and black still
has this Knight which I don't have any
Pleasant words to say so I'm not gonna
say anything but I would be very unhappy
with the knight yeah 95 was played but
now she plays 97 and what is your plan
this is the problem you don't really
want to play a four here not a move you
want to look for maybe six is coming
next maybe didn't put the net on c4
Knight on c4 by the way it would not be
fun right not to mention this nights
almost trapped I don't know if you
realize this so you have to be very very
careful so Smith there decides you know
what I messed this position up and I
don't know if what he did is objectively
best but I really like what he did
because it made it so that his position
was still in my opinion at least the
easier one to play but he made a very
interesting decision here and this is
what I mean by the power of resetting
there's no doubt in my mind after ninety
seven he was like alright Peter you
screwed this up what's wrong with you
etc etc and then he was like alright
let's reset I don't want to take on d7 I
don't want to play f4 so what do I do
ah that's a little bit too far on the
reset button I don't think you actually
want to give up the two nights for a
rocking pun I'd say the pieces are gonna
be stronger I mean especially a knight
gets into c4 this outside past pawn then
really matters in those kind of
positions I would say that's probably
too much but I do like the radical
thinking that'll take you far what else
we got
yeah very nice so you give up a pawn but
what do you get in return so again I
don't know if objectively this was the
way to go it's it's hard it's really
hard to say even the computer it
probably is not so sure but your
position now becomes easier to play you
get a rook on the seventh rank you're
targeting this f7 pawn blacks Bishop on
a4 is a little messed up and by the way
if your opponent has pieces on the edge
of the board I'm looking at you night on
h5 and Bishop on a4 you want to try to
open the position you want your pieces
to flow you want to get threats because
black is not well equipped to deal with
them with pieces scattered like this you
know what I mean so I like looking for
ways to take the initiative when your
opponent has dubious pieces so again I
me can't claim whether this is good or
bad I'm not an Oracle and I'm not alpha
zero but I would say that this is an
idea I like and probably I would want to
play so rook f8 so how do you build your
position
hmm I actually like doubling rooks on
the sea plow the only thing is you have
to make sure that this night gets
defended in all this but he decided to
go after the C pawn the a pawn rather so
she defended it always repeat now
there's a very specific reason by the
way you always repeat it could be time
the very true but say your opponent has
less time
brookies 7 that's a good question it
could be because after rook e6 you're
not gonna really be able to take that
pawn because this nights gonna be pinned
right I can play rook to e8 on you maybe
or try something else I don't know I
mean it's still not that easy after rook
d8 they're still oops
let's see they're still maybe this maybe
this move so you can't take coz I can
take back but maybe here looks kind of
weird though right Jake stakes yeah I
don't know this bishop is so silly
though right like what is it doing
yeah I don't know I mean the net on d8
though it looks weird - it's just a mess
right but it could be he doesn't really
want to take hmm ah
rook b6 the problem is you need a way to
trap it King that's gonna be a little
slow I can probably get to you before
then so maybe here rook test e7 rook c6
it's a good idea I mean trying to trap
the night but I think it's a little slow
why it's not completely helpless but I
would say that black has to be very
white has to be a little careful with
the position like this keep in mind also
it's not up any material right so that's
the thing sometimes when you have
initiative there's a tendency of people
to want to cash in too early they want
to take their material back right away
they're like I don't want to be down
upon but sometimes if you take back to
your pawn you give up all that major
position nice you know so that's
probably why you didn't do that however
my question was not that my question was
why repeats
that could be true you also see where
your opponent's at is my opponent okay
with the draw do they want to try to
beat me here they're up upon what do
they think about the position sometimes
when you repeat you get information
about your opponent and as you pointed
out which is quite correct there are a
lot of times when Pete you repeat your
opponent in order not to repeat plays a
bad move happens all the time so I'm you
have to be careful with this if you're
repeating a lot in positions that are
similar you don't want to repeat three
times right I actually had a very strong
GM do that against me where I was just I
had a worse position I was suffering I
don't know if I was lost but I it was
not fun and he accidentally repeated
three times so yes I can go home but in
general repeating can be a really nice
powerful tactic I would say almost all
GM's do use this trick where they repeat
a lot and if a GM's repeating against
you it does not mean they want to draw
they're trying to feel you out they're
trying to figure out what you're doing
so I'd say unless you really want you
think you're better
repeat fairly quickly do not let them
gain time do not let them kind of figure
things out
give them no information but it is a
very common trick and I'd say you know
most people do it in a case he didn't
want to draw she was having a bad
tournament so - is extremely strong
she's out raided in this tournament
she's one of the players who probably
people want to beat just cuz she's one
of the lower rated players
but she's just having a rough event
she's not in my opinion she's not
particularly well prepared like I don't
think her openings have gone that great
for the most part you know it could be
she's gonna go to school next year she's
focused on other things I don't know
maybe she's off form it happens to
everyone I would say audubon is also in
very bad form as well and that can
happen with him because he's a very
aggressive player so if he's playing
badly it can be really bad of course the
opposite is true if he's playing well so
yeah I thought I saw a hand
but I can't see very much so it's all
good so rook c1 was played so he wants
to play on
she played d4 trying to play actively
again another very common trait in GM
games if GM's make mistakes often it's
because they try to be too active they
they don't want to play passively so
they play an active move which maybe
isn't best so I don't know if this move
is actually bad or good but I would say
that it's a little bit risky because
you're giving away a pawn however she
wants to be active she wants to be
aggressive but I think that white
actually had a good move here so the
question is you have to make a choice do
you play with do you play with an e4
type idea or do you play with captures
so actually sorry I should point out
that g4 was played first so g4 9 f6 so
here you have the choice between playing
efore and trying to run with your pawns
or trying to take this pawn
is there a line as their reasoning is
there so again it's there is some
measure of calculation there's I'd say
this is mostly calculation but there's
also a pawn structure element I think he
played his move because of pawn
structure more than anything else he's
aware that if you get E for f4 g4 and
these pawns start rolling that's an
extremely powerful structure that's very
good for the initiative and I think that
he wanted the initiative whereas after
pawn takes pawn
he thought that black would probably
play rook d5 and now this pawn gets
taken this pawn structure by the way not
as good you have a whole you're not
really doing anything but in this
position he had a really really cool
resource which I think he missed and it
could be he was in time pressure here so
I wouldn't blame him for missing this in
time pressure but you guys aren't gonna
miss it of course
Knight takes on on b5 you're yeah this
this is I would say this is risky would
be the nice word for removing this even
even if I take with the Bishop I'll be
able to take on a to attend you're
certainly not really playing for
anything now right okay but I do like
the tactical view looking for tactics is
always good night c8 threatening a fork
in the night the problem is I can either
play King g7 or rook takes d4 even right
rook takes d4 probably and then
so you guys are looking for tactics
tonight when material which of course
you should be but given that none of
that works do you have a way to kind of
you need a gluing tactic was that too
cryptic do you guys know what I mean by
a gluing tactic I just made it up so you
probably don't what it means is that a
way to glue your position together
tactically to make it so black can't
capture stuff because you have tactics
it's a type of tactic that sometimes
people miss people want to take stuff
but sometimes you just have to stop your
opponent from doing it so you can play
rook see a check and now look at that
this moves actually quite nasty because
say black plays h6 trying to prevent g5
type moves logical right 98 you just
move your king it doesn't really do
anything
this should be four I don't think so I
can take on d6 take 76 after Bishop e5
but there's a question that people often
forget to ask themselves which is what
is black gonna do next
what is blacks next move I'm very
curious if you move the a pawn you don't
have anything else if you move the
b-pawn I have Bishop c4 right this
Bishop only has one move it's not
particularly thrilling so what if I just
go here and laugh
this should be - looks fine also but
this should be - maybe Bishop C - Bishop
here your PIN still bishop before anyway
you're still oh but then Bishop takes I
see yeah
Bishop e2 might be good as well but I
was thinking even just even just not do
anything yeah
big deal kind of funny right you can but
what does that do I'm just gonna wait
okay I could play King III and try to do
stuff too but the point is that black
basically has no moves at all
yeah cuz it probably black has to play
King h7 at some point but then you can
just take enough stone kind of funny huh
so sometimes these things are a little
unexpected but the idea is that this
this is actually very solid even though
you're pinning yourself because of
tactics and this rook all of a sudden
doesn't feel so hot so my guess would be
if he saw this he would have taken on d4
but he played e4 rookie six so of course
what happens now this pawn structure is
very dangerous almost always and note
how this pawn is not really doing much
of anything right you have to be careful
because there are times when you need to
move this bishop to activate to give
yourself an initiative and then all of a
sudden this pawn and this Bishop looked
like they work together you know it's
you have to be a little cautious black
played b4 which does make a threat it
turns out
yeah f5 it turns out would have been a
good move but this was all a little bit
complicated so you can see now that the
whatever turned from like at Carlsbad
which is like a very positional battle
to b5 happened and then tactics broke
out so this happens all the time that
your game goes from a positional one to
a more tactical one and you have to make
sure that you're kind of going along
with the ride if you try to play by the
way a very positional game tactically
like you're trying to attack step
every move you're gonna play pretty
badly but if you try to play this
position purely positionally you're
obviously not gonna have a very easy
time either so usually you have to find
kind of a happy mix but I guarantee you
he just liked this pawn structure I
would like this pawn structure we all
like this pawn structure but it's all
very concrete so this happened Aoife all
makes it all make sense right
95
this is why you have to be a little
careful this be if you take on C's on e6
this be this deep on doesn't look so
weak anymore does it all of a sudden
it's running up the board at in record
time this pawn is gonna be Usain Bolt
it's just gonna be going it that is
indeed what he did and unfortunately yes
so what should black do here it's a
complicated position take a few minutes
there's no rush we got time because in
my view what she had to do here was it
wasn't that it was complicated to
calculate it was difficult to kind of
realize that this is the way to play yes
King h6 I'll take on f7 with the knight
and then laugh
so I don't think this idea is all that
strange I think it looks pretty nice my
question I guess is what happens after
this move that's the move I would fear
slightly and if you try this which looks
to solve all your problems I can go like
this and then check and take back the
roof yep when tactics work they're
pretty cool
I wouldn't know my games they don't work
but and in other people's games they
look real fun so what else you got
I'm imagining right now someone walking
in let's see what pawn structure he's
talking about it sees this mess so d3 is
what was played in the game but there's
a fatal flaw to that one I think so
but you have to come to terms with
something it's not so much about
calculating it's kind of like accepting
a loss it's like a grieving process you
have to be like okay this is the way
things are I'll make the best of it and
I'm guessing she had almost no time
which means that this was extremely
difficult but it's more of a mindset
thing than a calculation thing even
worse yeah the problem is if you give up
the exchange you're not just giving up
the exchange you're giving what a
monster pom right so just try taking
stuff not what could go wrong well I
would take I would take this guy first
King h2 for example King G 2 is pretty
similar I think just take you allow this
looks bad right but okay D 3 very nice
if Bishop takes this is a nice fork note
how the rooks actually badly placed
because the knight wants to be there and
what exactly does white do now
probably White has to stop d2 right but
now you play rook III check King up
attacking this pawn how many pawns does
white I have left but it's not gonna be
2 for long right so you see what I mean
sometimes all you have to do is think
wait a second what happens if I give
back a piece what happens if I give up
this and it's hard to do because you're
trying to look for a solution which
solves all your problems you want to be
like all right I save my piece and take
pawns and Queen my pawn and I'm the
champion sometimes it doesn't work that
way sometimes you just have to go okay
I got to give up a piece but what can I
get for it and that's the hard part
calculating this is not hard right
what's hard is to realize okay I have to
go of a piece it's okay
I've given up worse than pieces
I certainly have so yeah this was what
was necessary unfortunately she did not
do this she played d3 and I'm guessing
she just blundered here so rook takes f7
rook takes f4 and what is the problem
now and both this and this hang so if d1
I can just take it and that's kind of
where her position goes amok so she just
resigned because now she's gonna be down
a piece for nothing pretty much because
you can't even take this pawn because of
Knight f7 so I guess you can you then
you get the rook back but you're gonna
be down pretty much a whole piece so
that's not gonna work out so well right
so again crazy game you know the pawn
structure part of it really was you know
the beginning right it was like okay
white tried to put her knight on e5
white tried to play for b4 so there were
very typical Karlsbad ideas but as you
saw what happens when after b5 happened
was the game anywhere near positional
just blew up into tactics right away
right and that's often the way it works
so part of it is I'd say if you have to
take away anything from this game it's
first of all be flexible with your plans
was he super attached to the 95 was he
super attached to one plan or another no
right he was willing to change his mind
it's an important thing know the ideas
of your structure but sometimes you have
to go apart from them sometimes the
regular ideas don't work you have to do
something unusual to my mind Queen a 4
and B 4 was really weird looking but for
that position it worked out well and
then after that just calculate tactics
well and don't miss Knight Forks is the
main gist of that so anyway you know not
exactly a classic example but I hope you
guys enjoyed the game and maybe learn
something about pawn structures or
hanging pieces or something
[Music]